翻訳: Leanna Marquart
校正: Mai Iida
「日本人で良かった」と思える日本を
子どもに残すには
ということで
早速皆さんに質問があります
皆さんは 文化と経済
どちらが大切だと思いますか
じゃあ 文化だと思う人
手を挙げてください
あぁ すごい TEDxに来る人は皆さん
文化を大事にしてくださってますね
じゃあもう一つ
経済の方が大事だと言う方
あぁ すごい正直ですね
ありがとうございます
こんな質問をしたんですけれども
私は 文化と経済
両方大事だと思います
じゃ皆さん もしも皆さんがですね
生命を維持するためだけに
水分補給をしていたら
このコップ一つで足りると思いませんか
でも実際私たちの世界には
たくさんのコップがありますよね
みなさんこれ何に使います
酒　日本酒飲みますね
これは
コーヒー
じゃあ これは
なんかいいでしょ
ビール飲みたくなりますね
じゃあ　はい
ワインね これとってもグローバルです
これは
日本のお抹茶
じゃあこれ難しいですよ これ
これ単純に私が楽しみたくて
何を飲むかではなく
このコップで飲みたかったから買ったコップ
こんなにコップ
皆さんが もしも
こういう文化がなければ
必要としていないと思うんです
つまり 私たちの先人は
「これで飲んだら日本酒おいしいなぁ」
「いやいやいや でも同じ日本酒でも
漆器じゃなくてこういうちょっと
鎚起銅器の方が口当たりがいいぞ」
とかですね
一つのものを飲むにも 色んな飲み方
それ 私たちの五感を活用した
そういう「美味しさを楽しむ」っていう文化を
育んでくれたからこそ
たくさんのコップが必要です
そうすると つまりですね
経済にとっても文化が大切だし
文化にとっても経済が大事だと思うんです
私は文化が経済を育て
経済が文化を育む そう思っています
でも 今 私たち日本人は
急激に日本の文化を失おうとしているんです
そこで 今日は
私が皆さんに
日本の伝統を次世代に繋ぐためのアイデアを
お話ししたいと思います
皆さん この数字何かわかりますか
1-9-8-8
日本にとってすごいことが起きた年です
そう 経済の絶頂を極め
そしてそこから
ジェットコースターのように落ちていった
バブルの最後の時です
そしてこの1988年は
私が生まれた年でもあります
1988年に私は生まれました
東京で生まれて千葉のベッドタウンで育ったんです
家族４人
すごい典型的な核家族ですね
祖父母はマンションに住み
私には田舎がありませんでした
もう 本当に 友達がですね
「秋田のおじいちゃんおばあちゃん家に
一ヶ月夏休み行ってきたんだ」っていう話を聞くと
もう 羨ましくてしょうがなかったんです
私は なぜかわからないんですけど
田舎が羨ましいし
日本の 伝統とか文化に
ものすごい憧れている日本人で
中学高校時代は茶花道部という
茶道と花道の部活動に入って
日本をとにかく感じたかったんです
日本に憧れた 私は
もともとジャーナリストを
目指していたんですけれども
せっかく私が何かを伝えるのであれば
日本のこと 日本の伝統を伝える
ジャーナリストになりたいと思って
大学時代 日本各地に飛び出して行って
色んな職人さんを取材して回りました
すごくですね 面白かったのが
私 毎日 プラスチックの箸でご飯食べてました
でも職人さんのところに行ってから
漆の箸を頂いたんですね
で 漆の箸でご飯を食べるようになったら
毎日同じご飯のはずが
前より美味しく感じるようになったんです
なんか伝統ってすごいぞ
他にも職人さん達って
なんでそんなこと知ってるの
っていうことたくさん知ってるんです
「この葉っぱを取って
これはね こうやって揉んでね
こうやってやると
ほら 藍の色が出てくるでしょう
この葉っぱは 藍の葉っぱで
実は紫外線カットしてくれたり
保温効果もあるんだよ」とか
すごい色んなことを教えてくれました
私はこの伝統って面白い
もっともっと伝えたい
と思ったんですけれども
現実を知った時に驚きました
もし皆さんが職人さんだったとしたら
たった この1990年から2009年の間に
この4分の1の人たちが仕事を失うんです
そして生産額を見ても
3分の1になっていたんです
どうして 私はこんなに
面白いし人の役に立つ伝統が
こんなになくなってしまったんだろう
ということを
すごく不思議に思いました
それからですね 私は
どうやったら これを日本の
もっともっと 色んな人達に
知らせることができるのかなって
一生懸命大学生なりに考えました
その時にですね
「ああそうか」と
なんでみんなが知らなくなってしまったのかというと
私 小学校 中学校 高校
大学 大学院って出たけど
全然日本のことを教えてもらう機会なかった
それは学校だけじゃなくて
親からも教えてもらえない世代になっていた
でもこれって誰が悪いとか
そういう話ではなくて
うまく伝統が循環しなくなっていたんですね
私はこの日本の日の丸 伝統や先人の知恵に
今この会場にいらっしゃる皆さんの
感性や感覚がこの円だとして
これらを「和える」ですね
日本の和え物
日本の伝統や先人の知恵と
現在生きる私たちの感性 感覚を
和えることで 新たな伝統を見出し
次の世代に繋いでいく循環を考えました
それが 赤ちゃん 子供達に
伝統を伝える方法だったのです
例えば こうやって職人さんが
藍染 一生懸命かき回します
これを赤ちゃん達のために
どうやって使うかな と思うと
こういう藍染の上着ができます
じゃ 子供達が持ちやすいように
高台にちょっと凹凸をつけたお茶碗作ろう
子供達が正しい日本の所作で
食べ物を食べられるようになる
そして この和紙のボール
色んな伝統産業の職人さんと
赤ちゃん 子供達に
ものを通して伝えるジャーナリストに
私はなろうと思って
就職場所を探したんですけど
なかったんです
それで大学時代に この「aeru」という会社を作って
まずは 日本の伝統を次世代に繋ぐための
循環を作るための
会社を生み出しました
「aeru」は この他にも
色んな伝統をつなぐアイデアを
たくさん生み出している企業です
私が この「aeru」を立ち上げた時に
新聞記者の方から取材を受けたんです
「矢島さんは 失われた20年の世代が
初めに社会に出る
その時に 今 会社を立ち上げられましたね
この なお失われ続けている日本に
未来を感じますか」って
聞かれたんです
皆さん 未来感じてますか？
私は それを聞いて初めて
「そうか 私は 失われた20年の世代」
つまりロストジェネレーションだと
大人達に思われてる世代だったんだって
初めて気がついたんです
つまり バブルを経験した方々からしたら
こんなところから ここまで落ちたら
失われたー
経済が失われた20年だと思うんです
でも ここから始まった私にとっては
大して変わらない
そして もちろん日本にも今 貧困の問題はあります
けれども 全世界で見たら
すごく豊かな国だと思うんです
つまりですよ 失われた20年の世代が
本当に失ったものってなんだと思いますか
私は それは 経済ではなく
文化だったんじゃないかなと思ったんですね
急な経済成長のために
経済の中で経済を回し始めてしまった
でも それだと 私たちの文化っていうのが
文化に経済が再投資されなくなった時
文化は置いていかれてしまったんですね
そして私は もう一度
本当の意味で
豊かな次の世代を生み出すには
今を生きている私たちが
一体何をすればいいのか
ということを考えました
100年前の先人が 私たちのために
木を植えてくれました
だから今日私たちは 木を切って
自分たちの必要なものを作れます
でも 今 木を切った私たちは
百年後の人のために
木を植えているでしょうか
皆さん きっと この会場から一歩外に出たら
色んな顔を持っていると思います
企業の人かもしれないし
家庭の人かもしれないし
色んな顔を一人の人がたくさん持っていると思います
でもどんな顔の時にも 私たちは
少しだけ次の世代のことを考える
ただそれを みんながやることで
本当に豊かな世代を
次に残すことはできるのではないでしょうか
最後に もう一度皆さんに聞きます
文化と経済
どちらが大切でしょうか
私は この質問を
日本人が そして世界の人がしなくていい社会を
皆さんと一緒に作れたら嬉しいなと思います
是非 一緒に 次の世代が 20年後
「日本人で良かった」
と思える日本を残しませんか
ありがとうございました
（拍手）